die lage ist sehr gut
neues album raus wenn du mit paks schon
wieder lateinisch richtig wie der
lateinisch wieder ein stilelement
benutzen wie so oft ich find's einfach
cool
ich bin nicht mal der lateinischen
sprache fließend mächtig so es geht
einfach darum ich finde es geil wenn die
leute noch mal hingehen müssen nicht
direkt auf den ersten blick wissen worum
es geht also geld müssen sich schon mit
dem gedanken also mit dem titel
auseinander sind vermissen sich gedanken
machen was da auf sie zukommt oder was
da auf sie wartet und ich denke das gibt
noch mal so ein anreiz ein bisschen die
spannung zu steigern so und ich finde es
ganz gut hat dass sie irgendwann mal
eingeführt und ich bleibe jetzt der
bericht in troja und pax lateinisch
heißt krieg und frieden ist das auch ein
bisschen das motto für das alkohol also
eine gute mischung aus sonst wurde
einfach nur bescheuert spielen sollte
und nicht viel nachdenken sollte und auf
der anderen seite natürlich auch wie man
es von mir ein bisschen kennt und die
dinge wo man auf dem voraussage hat oder
zum nachdenken angeregt wird also nicht
dumpf einfach nur bedienen so ein
bisschen aber das andere ist stumpf
anfahren bewegen was es ist eher die
unterhaltungs schiene sie heißt das was
man auch von mir halt kennt so zum
beispiel bei einem track wie stammt der
nazis oder rap und ich da kann ich
natürlich nicht sagen dass jetzt eine
tiefgründige message inter steckt so
weißt du mich hier als lehrer auftun so
aber es ist halt so dass es krieg um
fehlen dieses element dadurch deutlich
wenn rapper über schimpfwort lustige
texte reden dann sagen sie immer
unterhaltung sind schimpfwörter
unterhaltung
ich weiß nicht ich denke es ist einfach
es ist ein teil davon
ich denke es ist wenn man den humor teil
das ist dass humor oder ist das genau
das gegenteil von humor weil sein
spezialthema kasten da ja man muss dass
man muss das für sich selbst entscheiden
ob man das mit sich selbst vereinbaren
kann wenn man es gibt natürlich bestimmt
leute die deren nicht diesen humor teil
ich persönlich kann man immer nur dazu
sagen dass es sehr spießig ist weil ich
glaube roll ist es auch darum geben
soweit sie da sagen
sagen die auch wiese sachen heute
vielleicht nicht hin oder die engen
texte sind englisch so keine ahnung und
ich mein haus musik dasselbe ich meine
wurzeln wird diese musik gemacht damit
sich welche sollte auf drogen vollpumpen
von dem klub tanzen gehen dann muss dazu
sagen auch bietet texte waren zum teil
nicht denkbar schon damals aber wenn ihr
sagt jetzt unterhaltung was ist das
unterhalten an schimpfwörtern oder ist
es oder was ist das humorvolle weil sie
teilweise denken ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
ich denke oder andere leute denken hey
das ist ja einfach nur doof eine sauerei
also ich sag mal nicht bei seinen
zuhörern aber die leute die nichts damit
anfangen kann ja das also um auf deine
frage einzugehen
das ist ein schmaler grat zu nerven
alles so und ich persönlich sagt wenn
das jetzt so darum geht dass man sagt
dass schimpfwörter die unterhaltung sind
dann bin ich vielleicht das so fein raus
dass ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die ganze
zeit durch gegen schreiben das ich komme
und genau wie seine mutter durch die
durchs wohnzimmer oder seinen vater mit
einem gag sondern einfach so ich
versuche das schon auf jeden fall mit
charisma zu verpacken ich denke wir mal
nach rein hört merkt man dass auch das
ist vielleicht nicht so unbedingt
gleiches wie bei vielen anderen aber
nichtsdestotrotz hast du recht ich kann
auch leute verstehen beziehungsweise
nachvollziehen die sagen hey das ist
nicht mein ding so weiß ich ich sage ja
auch ich kann auch nicht jeden und alle
jeden musiker nachvollziehen so und wenn
er einerseits und es wird zu zu brachial
das geht mir zu sehr an die nieren so
dann kann ich damit leben so das ok für
mich so weiß ich erwarte auch nicht von
jedem dass er meine musik liebt so ich
meine es ist wie es ist so und am ende
kann ich nur das machen was mir mein
herz sagt mir mein herz sagt so jetzt
wird auf die kacke gehauen da hierdurch
die kecke gewann sagt ihr dass dein herz
oder wie kommt dass die komma ist somit
der rap metal szene zu tun das natürlich
der spaß ich glaube mir ist es so ein
bisschen des sternzeichen zwilling ich
bin im juni geboren und hier wirklich
ich glaube mein charakter also jetzt
nicht zwei gesichter im sinne von ich
mach dir ein vorn im nachhinein bin ich
gar nicht so sondern auch eric und
frieden im krieg und frieden gibt es
also im sinne von vielleicht so dass man
meine gemütslage die schwankt schnell um
so ich kann
jetzt im augenblick mit dir sitzen gut
drauf sein und reden und im nächsten
augenblick mir ein kollege und das
spiegelt es denke ich meiner musik auch
wieder soweit ich habe auf jeden fall
eine menge lieder wo ich einfach sehr
melancholisch oder erhalt melancholisch
tiefgründige sachen macht aber im
nächsten moment einfach komplett
wahnsinniges zeugs redet dinge total
übertrieben darsteller einfach weil ich
sie dann in dem moment den humor feier
sowieso und das ist das ding was europa
mit paks sehr deutlich wird krieg und
frieden zusammen zu bringen
okay was hast du leuten die das
vielleicht deine texte ein bisschen zu
ernst nehmen und sagen ja finde ich gut
in dem was ich jetzt nicht bei dir aber
ich [ __ ] deine mutter wissen die das
feiern und sagen ja krass dass der das
um also die denken das ist so gemeint
oder ist es so gemeint nein natürlich
nicht also ich meine ich bin jetzt also
kein vorzeige kann hätte dass du die
ganze zeit bleibt aber ich sage ganz
ehrlich ich finde es lustig verpackt ist
das geil sie aber es muss lustig sein so
ist darf mich einfach so stumpf sein
dass du sagst ich [ __ ] deine mutter so
dass das will ich gar nicht hören ich
witzig lustigere sachen hören so weißt
du so einfach wenn du wenn du es geil
verpackt ist es immer vertretbar
nur wenn jetzt jemand sagt das ist nicht
sein ding so dass der 40 er persönlich
von angegriffen
dann tut es mir leid dann davon ist die
tür so keine anderen ziehst du nicht
rein weil dann dann dann das rein was du
willst ich meine es auch jedem selbst
überlassen
nun ich bin ehrlich der meinung ich
finde es schließlich wenn man sein wenn
man sagt dass es mir zu vulgär
weil wenn man sich in einem alltag
umschaut da passiert viel mehr sexismus
und zu viel mehr sage ich mal
perversitäten als dass man das
verurteilen würde so aber die leute sind
dann glaube ich oben gehen oberflächlich
ans werk so oder bzw oberflächlich an
die sache die hören dieses spezielle
sache und bleiben alles andere aus so
die achteinhalb vielleicht nicht aus so
sachen die web fanatiker cool finden wie
wortspiele oder raumstrukturen oder was
auch immer kassen floss so nebensächlich
gelten drücken wir vielleicht locker mit
der sprache urlaub karasch paarungen ich
weiß noch als ich klein war es ähnlich
lange her
dann dürften bin also wenn wir scheiße
gesagt haben das war schon eine
katastrophe
also und dann auch ich sag mal vor 20
jahren was oder durfte man auf einer
bühne nicht scheiße sagen sogar komplett
verboten sind und heute gang und gäbe
bedeutet es eigentlich verklemmt
letztlich immer wenn man emotional wird
benutzer keiner kann sie ja davon frei
machen wir einfach total verklemmt oder
eine gute freiburg wir verklemmt sind
oder ob wir einfach nur so ein
spiegelbild so vom tv sind der uns den
ganzen tag voll flimmert die frage ist
ja was ist perverser so den ganzen tag
irgendwelche nachgestellte idioten
sendung über den bildschirm laufen zu
lassen und die jugendlichen damit zu
füttern oder ist es perverser den leuten
zu sagen scheiße oder kaka oder du
[ __ ] was auch immer wie man das
ausdrücken will ich persönlich bin der
meinung aber das ist nur meine
persönliche meinung dass dinge wie
brennpunkt familien im brennpunkt
familien dort familien hier junge frau
sucht model model sucht biest das finde
ich persönlich perverser weil die ganzen
leute sitzen abends soll trotz also
pumpen sich das rein und uns wird
vorgegeben es wäre also das ist das
schlimmste ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich
mittlerweile hat das auch jeder so ein
bisschen durchschaut aber trotzdem
ziehen sich einfach viele rein weil es
einfach unterhaltung für die darstellt
und da sind wir bei einem punkt
unterhaltung so was ich gerade gesagt
hat wo unser humor hin geht so ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob man jetzt das eine mit
dem anderen messen kann so das sollte
überhaupt nur ich find's ganz ehrlich
einfach perverser wenn du jetzt sage ich
toleriere die ganze scheiße dem
fernsehen läuft zum beispiel diese
vollidioten bei dschungelcamp also ich
meine was was es daran noch roman wenn
jemand da hingeht und für geld irgendwie
scheiße frist die kein normaler mensch
essen würde bei so einfachen prinzipien
gegen den normalen prinzipien eines
menschen verstößt scheiße von
irgendeinem tier zu essen
aber was haben wir diesmal auch gegessen
hast selber schoss es werden wie es wird
alles es empfiehlt diese wahnsinnig und
dann hin zu gehen und zu sagen ja
rapmusik verdirbt die jugend oder diese
wörter über die mir gerade geredet haben
auch der bühne zu sein scheiß oder so
wie gesagt da sehen wir das spiegelbild
der gesellschaft oder der flimmerkiste
ein so und eins von beiden sind wir
rapper weil wir sind das sprachrohr ich
glaube es gibt keine musik in der so
viel geredet wird mit zugesprochen mit
text hat wie ein rap musik und deswegen
denke ich sind wir irgendwo spiegelbild
von irgendetwas ob wir das aus dem platz
der das spiegelbild sind ich meine jeder
kann sich dafür über gewisse ripper ein
eigenes bild machen und sich dann eine
eigene meinung dazu bilden vom was er
gerade das spiegelbild ist auf jeden
fall irgendwie seit der sehr nah am
publikum weil rap ist im moment wieder
unglaublich erfolgreiche jbg 2 und ich
glaube du bist auch auf einem sehr guten
weg ganz ganz vorn mit dabei zu sein
warum jetzt so krass ich denke dass
einfach diese neue art diese neue
generation von web angekommen ist die
deshalb auch noch mal auf eine andere
stufe bringen bzw auf einem anderen
faktor das sind auf einem ganz anderen
level halten das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass die bremer vor nicht gut waren oder
so aber einfach zum beispiel es gibt ein
ganz einfach andere möglichkeiten das
internet lässt alles noch weiter
zusammenwachsen ich meine wenn man auf
facebook ich habe zum beispiel 600.000
likes auf meiner seite
auch wenn facebook viele dicht macht
trotzdem wenn man etwas geteilt neues
video das ist ja wie so ein virus der
sich verbreitet so und dadurch kommen
leute mit web in berührung oder
entdecken das für sich die vielleicht
vorher gar nicht die möglichkeiten
hatten weil ich meine das tv format ist
ja längst überholt und da über die
musiksender brauchen wir gar nicht zu
sprechen so dass sie nach gutefrage.net
keine aktie gesehen
keiner hat sie gesehen entspricht noch
darüber über die geschichte so und
deswegen denke ich dass es auch von
vorteil ist und man sich selber besser
präsentieren kann und die leute das
gefühl bzw
die leute das alles nachvollziehen
können wenn du den erhalt so eindrücke
gibt und die mit erwachsenen so und ich
denke das ganze hat sich schon vor 45
jahren abgespielt und jetzt siehst dass
diese leute älter werden und web halt
mit wächst besonders ist gerade auf
einem sehr guten weg und ich denke die
rapper die auch gerade am start sind
alle zu recht da wo sie sind
apropos sehr guter weg
mad men ist mit auf dem album eine
legende aus den usa wie bist du denn an
den gekommen
monate in blogs abgang
so war das wie eingefangen das war das
ist eine lange geschichte hat so ein
bisschen auch der zufall eingeleitet so
ein bisschen und ich bin auf jeden fall
froh dass der mit auf dem track ist
zweiter mittlerweile und das ist ein
derby doch was ich persönlich geld
findet das braucht man einfach ein sehr
entspannter typ ist wie du selber sagt
er hat diesen legenden status aber
derzeit sehr gezielt und der es
überhaupt kein bisschen so wie man jetzt
man jemanden erwarten würde dass der
innenraum tritt und die stadien einem
tag legt deshalb mit jedem cool wenn du
alt auf den col zuges ist auch ein sehr
entspannter typ und einer der lustigsten
menschen nicht immer in dem
kennengelernt haben wie geht man auf den
denn cool zu ich meine du deutschland
eher usa wie habt ihr das hingekriegt es
ist male das war es so dass der auf tour
war um ein busfahrer hat war der gleiche
der seine tour gefahren hat und der dann
zufällig ein altes album von mir die
ganze zeit läuft wasser und irgendwann
war redmond hat das die ganze
mitbekommen und zugehört und nebenbei
unbewusst und übernatürliche wurst jahre
hatte der connect uns nur irgendwie find
den typen kohlheim er doch so hat das
eine das andere wort gegeben und wir
haben natürlich uns ich habe mich
natürlich nicht zweimal bitten
das 19 warum oder sozial show und wir
haben es auf anhieb gut verstanden und
dann das ding hochgeht
was sagen die kollegen so was ich meine
dass die versuchen das runter zu schwer
war ja natürlich runter spielen
versuchen zu acht das ist doch irgendwas
hat doch jeder aber das ist ja das ist
ich freue mich auch sehr selber darüber
aber ich viele feiern das auch und ich
will jetzt auch ich weiß nicht wie die
anderen darauf reagieren aber für mich
persönlich ist es einfach noch cool weil
ich selber auch ein redmond verbinden
und seiner musik von da ist es noch mal
für mich jetzt nicht nur über den
feature das nicht gemacht habe um sag
ich mal nochmal zuhörer zu erreichen
sind einfach auch etwas worauf ich bock
hatte so und gleichzeitig dann auch noch
mal neue höhere damit zu erreichen ist
natürlich geil der modus das ist absolut
sensationell wie hast du denn davon
erfahren also war nach
wie war der moment hat das war das
angerufene mail oder kollegen in
stuttgart du hast doch auch eine
autogrammstunde war das noch ich will
nichts falsches sagen ich glaube das war
bei der nähe von frankfurt bei
weiterstadt hat eine autogrammstunde
man sagt ja okay dann hat er kommt noch
vor bei elektro auflegen dem club
gewinnt unbedingt kennenlernen und so
und dann denkt man in so einem moment
wenn man von so einer legende hat die
will nicht um wohin kennenlernen und
stand da das herz in die hose ich weiß
was ich schon hat man ganz cool ich habe
natürlich versucht cool zu bleiben ich
bin ja auch ne coole sau
spaß beiseite aber natürlich war ich
positiv aufgeregt
es war schon für mich so dass ich mir
dachte okay gut jetzt bleibt mir ein
bisschen sachlichen versuchte mich zu
zeigen so einen überfall ist aber es war
cool hat auch direkt so ich hatte das
gefühl nach zwei minuten das man zehn
jahre kämen so ein vertrautes gefährt
darüber gebracht und dann war das eis
direkt gebraucht also es musste nicht
zuerst um barriere gebrochen werden
von daher war das sehr sehr geil meiner
meinung nach okay die wie geht es weiter
also ich hab jetzt dieses album benno
max ich habe ich schaue wie es
weitergeht wir sind jetzt auf tour märz
und ich hoffe natürlich dass die leute
vorbei schauen wir sind in den ganzen
städten berlin frankfurt münchen köln
blatt schlag mich tun
du bist auch herzlich eingeladen das
album steht in den startlöchern in
berlin
ich glaube ich wird sich zwar am 30
okay die leute mal abchecken ob eventim
oder ethik und du kannst jederzeit
vorbei gekommen ich guck mal kann sein
ganzes team mitbringen ob man einen
bescheuerten serie drehen wie das
elektrisch eines webbrowsers okay und ja
wir sind halt bei der tour das album ist
am start ich hoffe dass die leute rein
hören werden so ein gutes ding geworden
schauen wir mal vielen dank ich denke
viel erfolg alles klar